Chicago is a very intense environment I
tell lots of people that I don't go to
work looking for compliments because
it's not it's we're very critical of
each other's work and so but there's a
notion that economics is very is to be
taken very seriously and it's to be
addressing important problems it's
supposed to be you know rigorous and at
the same time now relevant that
intensity i think has been very
important for that environment denis and
it kind of has kind of dominates lots of
interactions and i think it's really
been part of that the reason I Chicago
as an economics department or that
economic community has been so
productive also its economics as a feel
that it it advances and as it advances
that necessarily gets more specialized
Chicago has been very good at resisting
too much specialization there's lots of
interaction across areas and the like
that I think can really be important for
a creative research